nous sommes partis puis c'est un peu la
trame narrative de cette entrevue à
contrecoeur nous serions restés dans
leurs beats de la famille royale à l'
onu tt d'abord des commentaires racistes
comme viens de dire meghan markle et
n'eut été de l'absence d' aide de la
part de la famille royale devant les
cris de sos de megan marco marc
laurendeau journalistes analysent la
monarchie britannique marks bonsoir
bonjour patrice qu'elle était d'après
vous le but d'abord de l'exercice du
point de vue de de mégane et de du
prince harry il vient certainement de
leur côté une opération de relations
publiques la même si elle est à cet
égard une bonne interview deux emplois
et quand même fait partie de l'info
tellement payé du monde du spectacle et
s'était présentée avec des éléments de
ce spectacle vous montriez justement la
révélation où on apprend que
effectivement la couleur de peau du
futur héritier enfin de du fescarhy et
meggen aurait peut-être la peau un peu
france et elle dit what est lent mais là
vous savez vous êtes interviewer ont
fait pas ces choses là normalement
donc on ne charge pas plus que le témoin
ne le fait il y en a une dimension
spectaculaire faire de bonnes établir
une bonne image face aux américaines
certainement et en angleterre au système
campagne de relations publiques devant
nations can malgré tout nous mais ça ne
veut pas dire ça ne pas dire patrick et
pas des questions de fond vous soulignez
l'aide psychologique qu'elle n'a pas eu
sur ce plan la famille royale s'est pas
modernisé paris et si on fait un william
ont fait campagne continue ce qui est
arrivé à leur maire pour que la maladie
mentale soit considérée comme une
maladie à traiter et à considérer
sérieusement on a eu droit à la question
de race ou si le ca fait ça montre un
sectarisme
inouï le train d'attendre et chef du
commonwealth et que la majorité de la
population du commun
est d'origine racj en différents
secteurs vous normal qu'au bout d'un
certain temps il ya les membres de la
famille royale qui en soit 2,7 de cette
descendance afrodescendants si vous
voulez mais il ya des membres de la
famille royale qui sont les dix ans
c'est une découverte
le opération de relations publiques mais
meyer sérieux là dedans je pense que
c'est les confrères du monde ce matin
dit-il qui dans leur liste d'articles 10
elle lancé quelques grenades
dégoupillées ben oui enfin les journées
où l'on d'aujourd'hui la wii et
rencontres de l'immensité de
l'évaluation qu'elle fait fait référence
marqué l'histoire de diana la merde etc
on a l'impression que c'est une énorme
occasion ratée pour la famille royale de
se moderniser justement un accueil plus
en étant plus accueillants envers
michael mais que de vieux réflexes ont
réapparu parce qu'elle est devenue
vraiment là vilain de l'histoire pour
dans les tableaux et bien sûr qu'elle a
pas été défendu juste un fait oui
c'était évoqué durant durant l'entrevue
c'est à dire qu'il y avait des calomnies
il y avait peut-être un certain nombre
de choses vraies est le fait des erreurs
de jugement avait apparemment à le
porter et beaucoup de rake avec qui
venait de bin salman le savez princesse
et de prince héritier d'arabie saoudite
peu après l'assassinât de cash dit ya
peut-être eu un certain nombre d'erreurs
il ya eu des j'appellerai des querelles
de chiffres sont là parce que la mort de
la dame d'honneur était appropriée les
querelles avec qui et mais d'entendre
mes meilleurs sérieux aussi là c'est à
dire que l avait une forme de détresse
psychologique elle était comme
ostracisés et on ne lui a pas permis
c'est ce qu'elle est at il dit on ne lui
a pas permis de consulter un psychiatre
alors que c'est des valeurs pour devrait
accepter d'autres hauts fonctionnaires
sur demande
un des échelons décisionnel tel moment
donné ont besoin de recul les bains dans
leur vie c'est tout à fait je légitime
et normal vous et moi connaissons déjà
et ont consulté des psychologues et des
psychiatres
car ils ont su au contraire en même
temps marc j'entends beaucoup de gens et
et à hier pendant l'entrevue j'ai eu
quelques réactions qui m'ont amené à
m'interroger sur la crédibilité de mal à
marquer ce qu'elle disait toute la
vérité
vous faites allusion au fait que c'était
peut-être pas nécessairement facile
il ya hélas joue aussi en disant je ne
savais pas etc
or elle savait quand même dans quoi il
s'embarquait en épousant le prince nom
ou et oui c'est une personne qui vit
dans le regard des autres dans son
métier antérieur elle savait très bien
qu'elle serait suivie par les médias
elle mesure peut-être qu'elle ne dirait
pas l'ampleur et le changement que ça
amènerait avec la famille royale
c'est à dire que elle doit y avait un
certain mystère mais en même temps elle
doit composer au 21e siècle avec la
presse jean de fleet street qui n'arrête
pas de dénicher des patins député des p
tits qui vont prendre des photos
inopportune de la famille royale et
qu'ils envahissent constamment et
n'était peut-être pas habitué à ce
régime là d'autant plus est une des
révélations en entrevue que les après
que la famille royale compose avec sa
wii les proches ou à ces patineuses de
la presse de fleet street à l'occasion
alors que là le réflexe logique c'est à
dire aux gars à distance et vous
parlerez nous pour les choses
officielles
mais non elle la femme et moi le
composent est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
leur proche famille rose c'est de ne pas
être intervenu pour à l'égard des
calomnies à son sujet pour intervenir
pour rectifier les faits comme ils le
font à l'occasion pour d'autres membres
de la famille royale
on sait que leur explain never come
frame mais dans certaines circonstances
le secrétaire de la fin des mises au
point malgré tout et ils sont venus pour
faire parce que là c'est important quand
vous parlez de ces media markt ans va
quitter là dessus mais
on se demande même si la monarchie n'a
pas autant besoin de cette presse là que
2,7 que cette presse là a besoin de la
famille royale c'est vraiment ils sont
dans le même bocal
c'est le paradoxe parce que ce mystère
dont je vous parlais il ne veut pas se
cultiver avec une nés en constante
évasion de l'intimité que fait cette
presse à potins de faux faut la tenir à
distance
et oui est ce qu'elle se nourrit de sang
se nourrit davantage de profit de
circonstances de la l'aja presse un peu
plus généraliste
disons qu'à une autre époque
à l'époque la très recul victoria on
craignait pas la presse n'avait même pas
elle est très très très envahissante et
la sutie la famille royale qui
étrangement de vivre une relation
incestueuse avec cette fraise aurait dû
la protéger zippo kelly kelly sans
défaut un la nab ont seulement que dans
son entourage la harceler on dit ça mais
ça a été tellement amplifié qu'on lui
ait rendu la vie impossible
ensuite on ne reconnaît pas pu chauffer
specter price lui aussi puis on enlève
la garde
la camp auquel auraient droit à rue
alors l horizon 2 sur flins
non mais même si ce tte ya une dimension
business l'a très bien fait à cette
entrevue relations publiques
elle a raison sur planète seront marc
laurendeau toujours un plaisir journal s
analyse la version britannique merci
marc à la plage et au revoir